let's compare zero point one to zero
point zero seven zero so this one right
over here it is in the tenths place so
it literally represents 1 times 1/10 1
times 1/10 which is obviously the same
thing as 1/10 now when we look at this
number right over here it has nothing in
the tenths place it has seven in the
hundredths place so this is the hundreds
place right over here and then it also
has nothing in the thousandths place so
this number can be rewritten as seven
times as seven times one over 100 or
seven hundredths seven hundredths and
now we could compare these two numbers
and there's two ways you could think
about it you could try to turn one tenth
into hundredths and the best way to do
that if you want the denominator be
increased by a factor of ten you need to
do the same thing to the numerator so
all I did is I multiplied the numerator
and denominator by ten ten 100's is the
exact same thing as 1/10 and here it
becomes very clear ten hundredths is
definitely larger than seven hundredths
another way you could think about this
is look if you were to increment by
hundreds here you would go to seven
hundred or you start at seven hundred
eight hundredths nine hundredths and
then you'd get to ten hundredths so then
you would get to that number so this
number multiple ways you could think
about it is definitely larger so let me
write this down this is definitely
larger greater than this is greater than
that I the greater than symbol opens to
the larger value so here we have zero
point zero nine three and here we have
zero point zero one so let's just think
about this a little bit so this nine get
a new color here this nine is not in the
tenths the hundredths it's in the
thousandths place it's in the thousands
place and this 3 this 3 is in the I'm
running out of colors again this 3 is in
the ten thousandths place so the 3 is in
the ten thousands place so you could
literally view this as nine thousandths
nine thousandths +3 ten thousandths
three 10,000th and if you just wanted to
write it in terms of ten thousands you
can multiply the nine and a thousand by
zero and so it becomes 90 over
ten-thousand I need n thousandths and if
you want to add them together you could
of course write this as 93 ten
thousandth 93 ten thousandths
ten-thousandths I always have trouble
with that th S at the end now let's
think about this number right over here
0.01 well this one right over here is in
the hundredths place it's in the
hundreds place so it literally
represents one hundredth so how can we
compare 100 to ninety three ten
thousandths so the best way to think
about is well what's one hundredth in
terms of ten thousandths well let's just
multiply both the numerator and the
denominator here by 10 twice or you
could say let's multiply them both by
hundred so if you multiply by 10 once
you get to ten thousandths is the same
thing as 100 multiplied by 10 again you
get a hundred ten thousands is the same
thing as 100 then we know that 100 times
100 is 10,000 so here it becomes very
clear 110 thousandths or one hundredths
is definitely larger than 93 ten
thousandths so this quantity right over
here is less than this quantity they're
less than symbol the small end points to
the smaller number larger n to the
larger number in fact that's true of the
less-than and greater-than so let's see
this one right over here zero point six
versus 0.06 so here I have a six in the
tenths place so it literally represents
six tenths and here and in the second
around was six in the hundredths place
well the hundred six hundredths is
definitely smaller than six tenths 1/100
is a tenth of a tenth so this this one
is pretty straightforward this is going
to be the larger value zero point six is
greater than zero point zero six now
let's think about zero point three
versus zero point zero six so this three
literally represents three tenths three
tenths
well this six right over here well this
six right over here represents six
hundredths six hundredths and if you
wanted to compare
them directly you can multiply three
tenths times
well then both the numerator and the
denominator by 10 so you're not changing
its value 10 over 10 is essentially 1 or
it is 1 so this becomes 30 over 300 3/10
is the same thing as 30 over 130 over
100 is a lot larger than 6 over 100 so
this is greater than